You look gorgeous. It is so nice
to see you in person.
-I know.
It was all on Zoom last time.
-We were Zooming, but
I appreciate you doing it
back then because we needed
to entertain people.
So thank you so much.
Thanks for being here.
-Oh, it's so great
to be here in person.
-We were talking
about "Loki"...
-Yeah.
-...before it came out.
And now it's the most watched
Marvel series on Disney Plus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know, I know.
-It blew up, it blew up.
-I know.
It just got nominated
for six Emmys.
-That's right.
Well deserved. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How cool is that?
-Yeah, yeah.
-People love the show.
What was your reaction when you
saw it become the biggest thing?
-Oh, it was so surreal.
I mean, the whole experience
was amazing.
And for me to join something
that has such a huge fan base.
And obviously, Tom Hiddleston's
played that character
for such a long time.
So, to be, you know,
this morally ambiguous character
like Ravonna Renslayer has
kind of been really cool for me.
-It kind of introduced
the multiverse to the world.
-Yeah.
-Do you understand
the multiverse?
-Does anyone understand
-I don't know.
I'm a little -- I think I do.
I act like I do.
But don't test me on it.
-I know. I kind of feel
like we need a tutorial on it.
When we first started
the first season of "Loki,"
Tom gave us a big "Loki"
presentation,
kind of a PowerPoint on
his character and the history.
-Is that right? He explained it?
From Loki himself?
-Exactly.
-That's fantastic.
-From the horse's mouth.
But I feel like we need one
for the multiverse.
-Do you --
Are you filming season two?
-Yes, we just started.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Over in London, right?
-That's right, yeah.
-Everything is quiet
and under wraps and --
-It is. It is, I'm afraid.
I'm not allowed
to give too much away, but --
But, no, it's really,
really great to be back.
And it kind of
feels like, you know --
Because my character
deals with time
and the Time Variance Authority,
being back in that world,
it's -- it's like
no time has past.
-We talked about your paintings
last time.
You're an amazing artist.
I think you did at the time --
George Floyd was one you did.
-Yeah.
-You brought a picture of one.
You did a portrait
of Kevin Hart,
and it actually
looks exactly like him.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-That's amazing.
Why did you --
Why did you choose Kevin
over...other comedians?
[ Laughter ]
I'm just saying. I mean...
-No, I -- Yours is coming.
Yours is coming.
-I've been with you through
some hard times, COVID.
Zooming with you during COVID
and everything, yeah.
But Kevin gets
special treatment?
-Yeah, well, I'll tell you
the reason I chose Kevin,
we had just finished
a movie together.
We did a movie called "Lift,"
and it's set in the art world.
It's kind of like
an action heist thriller,
and he was constantly sort of
teasing me about my painting.
You know how Kevin
kind of likes to tease.
-Of course. That's why we don't
have him back on the show.
He's banned.
[ Laughter ]
-And, you know, he was
developing an interest
in art genuinely
during the show itself.
-Yeah.
-And I actually, during filming,
got COVID.
It was luckily a mild case,
but I had a bunch of time
off work.
-Right.
-Yeah, so, fortunately
it wasn't too bad,
and I got the paints out
because I was in isolation again
and so was able to give him
this painting of him as
a wrap gift.
-Did he love it?
-He loved it.
Yeah, he was really --
It was lovely.
It was really the last day of
filming and it was emotional.
-I think you got his eyes
perfect because he does have
kind of those
little puppy-dog eyes.
It almost looks like
he's crying sometimes.
-I know, I know.
-"Kevin, what's wrong?"
And he's like,
"Nothing's wrong!"
-Yeah, exactly.
-Starts yelling at me,
making fun of me, yeah.
Your show, "Surface,"
let's talk about this.
You star and
executive produce it.
-Yeah.
-That's a lot of work.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on this.
Can you explain --
Basically, you play a character
who's lost her memory?
-Yeah, yeah.
-And then she's trying to get
her life back together really.
-Yeah, that's right.
I play Sophie Ellis,
and the whole show
is a psychological thriller
set in San Francisco.
And basically, at the beginning
of the show, Sophie,
we discover, has lost her memory
after an accident.
And she sort of is trying
to put the pieces
back of her life together.
And she discovers that her
husband, maybe she can't trust.
And the whole -- There's
so many twists and turns,
but there's a sort of,
"did she jump
or was she pushed" element
to this accident.
And we sort of
get sucked into her life
and, you know, the glamorous
world of San Francisco.
It's really interesting.
-I want to show everyone
a clip right here.
Here's Gugu Mbatha-Raw
in "Surface." Take a look.
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
-Sir, which way
are you taking us?
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
♪♪
-You need to
get out of this lane.
-This is the best way.
Don't worry.
-No, no, no.
You don't understand.
This way goes over the bridge.
I can't go over the water!
♪♪
Just -- Just pull over, please!
-[ Sighs ]
-Let me out!
-[ Speaking foreign language ]
[ Handle rattling ]
-What are you doing?
-Let me out of the car!
-Alright!
Here. Alright. Unlocked! Go!
[ Belt clicks ]
♪♪
[ Horns honking,
indistinct shouting ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I will say, too...
Speaking of water,
there's a really good
underwater scene.
-Yeah.
-Which it's tough
to do underwater acting.
-Yeah, I mean,
I've watched movies and TV shows
with underwater scenes
my whole life,
but I have never done one.
And I have to say
it was kind of a real challenge.
I have to jump into this,
you know, big tank,
and every single time I jump --
and I just couldn't help
but sort of screw my face up.
And the director was like,
"You're screwing your face up.
You're, like, you know,
making this weird face."
And I'd be like,
"No, I'm not. No, I'm not.
I'm just holding my breath,
trying to stay alive."
-That's what someone would do
if they go underwater.
-Right, right.
And he's like, "No, no.
You're screwing your face up."
-"You're an actor."
-"Watch this.
Watch the playback."
And every time,
I was just like, "Mnh!"
And they were slowing it down.
And so it was
kind of really bad.
But it's like --
you're in your --
You're not in your
natural element, you know,
and your face does
such different things.
-So now you know how
to underwater act.
-Exactly.
-There you go.
Gugu Mbatha-Raw, everybody.
"Surface" premieres globally
July 29th on Apple TV Plus.
We'll be back with standup
from Pete Lee.
Stick around, everybody.
Come on back.